[Music]
Jim good morning - morning hi Ben hi
alright what happened getting into the
Academy Awards um well I got in my car
and I had all my tickets which included
the Oscars and the Governor's Ball and
the Vanity Fair party and I made sure I
had all those and I'm then I'm looking
at a text from my publicist who said be
sure and bring all that and bring your
ID when I was like oh so we're already
going and I text her back I said do I do
I for sure need my ID because I've gone
to I'd never gone to the Oscars but I've
been to like I've been to the Emmys
several times the Golden Globes several
times SAG Awards I've never taken ID
because I'm you just really don't need
it they do typically know who you are
when you get there and so I thought and
she goes yeah you need it and so I said
well we need to turn around and then we
try to turn around I went um mother of
hell I don't have a key and no one's
home so anyway I got here and I just
walked around outside for about an hour
and a half while I waited for Todd and
our friend Melissa to get back from a
friend they were visiting across town
and they let me in and I got my ID and I
left and I got there and plumy a time I
know that's not true I did not get there
in plenty of time I got in I got then
about 20 minutes where the show started
and they closed the bar they won't serve
any more because they want you to take
your seat so so wait wait wait you
really have a key to your own hills well
I knew that I didn't have anyone to get
back in so the last thing I was going to
do is go take a bunch of pictures in a
tight-fitting tux on the red carpet with
a keychain stick yeah you know I'm not
the best at the Hollywood stuff but I do
get that part I say you get there
whoo-hoo you're seated next to I'm
sitting next to one with a cast mate
from hidden figures Aldous Hodge and the
other one who's Oh what's his name Lucas
from hacksaw Ridge
kind of cameras last name starts of the
beat but uh they were really nice and
then I was right behind a agent of mine
and
he was a Scarlett Johansson and then
above them was Meryl Streep yeah that's
where I was sitting right right in the
middle okay so did we have the awkward
moment with Meryl Streep no no not one
not even eye contact
did you have an awkward moment with any
celebrity I I didn't I had a really
loving embrace from someone I never
imagined would know who I was which was
Salma Hayek who spoke to me literally
while we were getting our pictures on
that little I guess they call it the
step-and-repeat or whatever where you're
walking down it or whatever I hear like
hi I'm like how I look and I'm like what
the hell and the next thing I know she's
walking over to hug me and and III did
realize in that moment where Salma Hayek
is concerned there is no such thing as
gay and straight there is only some I
know isn't what you asked me no longer
matters when he meets a look she's
unbelievable
unbelievably hot yeah and just I don't
know what to call it besides some sort
of liquid sensuality of course all over
you
there's your just job I'll have a large
cup of that please a large glass of that
over there
all right now Long Island's on stage
when when do you realize well him yeah I
do so I really was I mean I went I'll
tell you this I felt close enough to the
stage that the first thing I did when I
said now was turn to the guy next to me
and say I'm did someone die how did I
end up sitting here so that's how close
I am so I can hear everything that's my
main point and they're up there they're
doing their speech and I start I hear I
hear from someplace on the stage I can't
see behind somebody's head I hear
moonlight moonlight and I and I'm like
what in that and I look and I see
there's a man on a headset kind of
coming up the stage sort of and that
looks like he's talking to the orchestra
section almost and I'm like what did
they did they play the wrong song and as
soon as I thought about it who cares is
this what it is and and then I thought
this is very
he's talking so loudly and then I
started to put it maybe without anyone
saying anything you start putting it
together and going what no and I thought
okay so how does this bit work out this
is another Kimmel bit and and and you're
looking at all those people from all and
going well this isn't very funny and I
don't understand how they would get them
all to agree to do something this absurd
and then the bottom fell out and it was
just I was like one of those moment
where everything kind of goes dark
around the corner and you're just and I
was like this is insane this is kind of
a nightmare
you know the the actor next to me kept
going it's so good we're here I'm so
glad we're here for this like yeah that
is it is a silver lining but I have to
tell you anything air for the end of the
day it's an award show that being said
in the moment I get like almost made you
feel nauseous it was like what the hell
we really I don't know it felt like
you're being punked it felt like a
nightmare to me it did what happens at
the after-party how much of the dialogue
was related to what happened on the way
out and into it was complete it was
completely absorbing it was completely
absorbing I mean you couldn't quit
referencing it it was because you know
there was every time you saw something
new you the first thing you said was oh
my god
it was crazy did you take a picture of
it no I saw somebody filming it to my
left and I just couldn't get myself
together to say and I know what I
thought I don't I don't know what I
would take up and they're filming this
it's being very well covered as it is my
footage won't help um I guess I gotta
turn the camera around myself and film
my own face but I didn't feel like it
could you imagine if your movie hidden
figures now one and then all of a sudden
moonlight then is announced as the
winner like you're wrong we were hoping
that they had made know we thought well
now there's a chance Gary get yourself
right with you would you have wanted to
have one for 90 seconds that no hidden
figurine for ninety say you're on stage
for the up there for 90
I think that was the start I mean look
both sides of it were so you know
ridiculous it was like do to get up
there can you imagine if you were like
oh my god I finally beat Bob Costas and
you get up there and you're making your
speech and then they go oh gosh all
those were worthless thank you those
weren't no no but I'm a gym I would take
that you'd like that moment it was
grabbed away from you at the end you
know what I would do I went run off the
stage with the Emmy I'd say come get it
Costas and he couldn't take me and but I
I would win that's what I would have
done if I'm lala land if I'm dying I
take the academy award I said oh my god
yeah what they want to work again you
know you've had a beautiful career you
can do whatever you want had a canonical
career no no it's still going on it's
not what it was it is going on what's
your next movie by the way I don't I
don't know I don't know because a few
things that are in the works are still
looking for finance like it's in that
it's there in that territory there's
nothing going that I know of yet there's
nothing going this summer that um that I
already know I have work for you want me
to get you into Sandler movie are you
sure okay I just do if you feel okay
about it you know I don't want you to
put yourself on the line and to be like
oh my god I recommended him what he did
yeah
you're not a diva though on stage you're
you know when when you showed out like
there's okay
because I've had my moments but you know
it's only one comes in with really bite
their heads off if you want to see Jim
Parsons alter ego hidden figures where
he plays a bad guy a mean guy you're not
you're not a good guy no I'm no I'm a
prideful man of a certain era and you
know who was the MVP I thought of the
Oscars Janelle Monae well she was in at
least two nominated movie maybe I'm not
you know why did you just thought she
looked great you know you talked about
it Salma Hayek is
being liquid sensuality like she was she
was a drum like a like a large drum of
like bass and true yes you're right
absolutely she look great
she did great alright um go back to work
I will I will a Big Bang Theory today uh
no we're doing a table read today so
we'll get the fresh script
oh wait wait did you get us something
from the Academy Awards you know the
only thing I have it don't let it go no
it's just I don't know that it's that
exciting but let me tell you this first
off I didn't make it past the Governor's
Ball because it was very scattershot and
at some point I finally found myself
completely alone and not like crying the
corner but like I didn't I didn't know
anybody anymore like I couldn't find
anybody from my cast
yeah Inge well no no it was fine I had a
lovely time and I enjoy going home
so at some point when I was supposed to
go to the Vanity Fair party I I finally
was standing waiting for my car and
going you know what I really want to go
home and eat and so I did and I went
home and I watched people arrive at the
Vanity Fair party on TV mmm it's a
better life for me but we I'm living
vicariously through you I got you I got
you well I'm just on thetic so well I
don't know if you think it is I got you
the program which I didn't realize this
is very nice program damn are you in it
my movie is what is your name I don't
think so I wasn't singularly why did you
get to or did you I don't want to take
the program because you got nominated
for you want the program dan I have
confidence
I'll get another program one of these
days thanks I'm at Shirley MacLaine yeah
all right
you got anything other yes a better than
then I didn't bring her back for the man
cave however you did not no no but but
like his Matt Damon come up to you just
Ben Affleck come on well I know Matt
Damon I go to the same gym as Matt Damon
so yes I talked to Matt and his
beautiful wife they're very sweet yeah
they were sitting right down the aisle
from me so we spoke can you bench me why
Matt Damon had come on
on people help each other can you bench
more than that Damon no but I can do
more on the sled this sled oh wait a
minute I saw the video where dad's on
the sled
yeah like you got legs like an NFL
lineman I have an odd amount of legs in
different mattifying that sir I really
do oh hey congratulations spying on
hidden figures and and you can have fun
at the table read today tell everybody I
said yeah and you tell everybody there I
will okay thank you Jim Parsons hidden
figures Big Bang Theory the Dan Patrick
show weekday morning on audience